this is a Michigan made 268 thousand
dollar supercar called the force one and
it's supposed to be the American answer
to everything that acid Martin or
McLaren can produce the Force One is the
latest brainchild from former General
Motors vice-chairman Bob Lutz and
celebrity car designer Henrik Fisker
this car you want to keep it exclusive
because we can cater to people who says
you know I already have a Range Rover I
already have a rolls-royce already got a
BMW 7-series but I want something really
unique something and nobody else have
something to have fun with and obvious
you have the money and then you buy this
type of stuff now this car is a little
controversial because Aston Martin has
claimed that Fisker is using some of the
main design elements that make aston
stevie 10 unique Fisker actually used to
work for aston martin but from the first
moment you see the force 1 you'll
realize there is absolutely no way
anyone would mistake it for an aston
martin the force 1 is characterized by
its enormous front end wheels push
incredibly close to the tip of the nose
a super long hood with massive air vents
a short windshield and a tight rounded
roof that swoops down into the rear the
spoiler on the rear end sets high and
holds the mechanics for the cars Wi-Fi
and for its rear brake lights it's all
meant to follow the flow of air as it
moves over this v10 machine the rear
window ends in a tiny wisp which is
unique to the Force One and it's
certainly the prettiest part of the car
the rest of it looks a little too much
like half a Corvette with maybe parts of
a Viper thrown in as well Fisker says
though that he already has people lining
up to buy one and he claims that he only
needs to build a handful of them anyway
to break even
he says he'll make about a hundred or so
in the first round it's an expensive
hobby making new cars like this but
Fisker doesn't seem to be in it for the
money for him it's about making very
special cars